thank you christian you know subaru of
las vegas the sponsors of this next
segment are all about spreading love and
as we remember 9 11 they're making sure
they're spreading love to our hometown
heroes here's their heartfelt tribute
you know uh burton we're back here again
and we're talking about
9 11 20 years later can you reflect to
remember where you were when you first
heard about it back then i was a
full-time pastor
and
i remember walking out of the master
bedroom and
turned on the tv for the morning news to
ready to get my coffee and
and i i saw the
the
news you know and and the
twin towers being hit by the planes and
of course i ran and grabbed my family
and
pulled them out to you know it was like
what am i looking at what am i seeing
here i hurt you up and got to i got
ready and i actually went to church and
i opened up the church doors and and and
uh
and just kept them open for people to
come and throughout the day actually
throughout the week people were driving
in and people that i'd never met before
and they would just drive in either they
would come in and sit inside the church
or they'd come in and they kneel and
pray or they would just sit there and
and want to talk for me
uh i was on duty that day and uh i
started at the gym when the towers were
were hit and by the time i had gotten to
the
station the towers had uh collapsed and
uh it was definitely a day of reflection
for us and um
definitely in our community uh the next
two weeks was
uh our way of giving back which i think
is what's so powerful about
our community and services what we could
do to support them from a distance this
is a special month and so
in your team's way of honoring uh
firefighters uh you're doing something
different could you elaborate on that
well several years ago we started uh
honoring our hometown heroes
and it's
it's born out of obviously a love for
for our first responders for what you do
every day and and my son gets to do it
with you
on the force and he has for 18 years and
and so
the opportunity to say thank you uh and
try
our best to convey
how much we care and how much we
appreciate and how much we need
the services you provide we want to take
this month from september 1st to
september 30th and we want to dedicate
50 for every new and used vehicle that
we sell or lease
to the professional firefighters of
nevada and we want to take three dollars
from every oil change that we do and we
do a lot of oil changes and we want to
dedicate that and hoping to raise
thousands of dollars for the work that
you do and the things that you would use
those money for
as a professional firefighter well on
behalf of
the pff and professional firefighters we
thank you and your team for uh thinking
of us and allowing us
to raise these funds to go towards a new
memorial and that will represent the 70
firefighters who over the course of the
last few decades have given their life
for
service to others
[Music]
thank you subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring that segment you can visit
them on roy horn way for more
information call 702-495-2100
or head to subaru of lasvegas.com